I love I love your accent I love an
Australian accent you're from Australia
you grew up there yes I did I grew up in
Adelaide South Australia Adelaide is
weird I don't I've been to Sydney I
don't know where Adelaide is exactly
down south okay now where all the great
white socks hang out perfect that's just
where I want to go good and and you go
back to Australia often I do I was
actually just there for Christmas
um I hung out at my dad's house he has
kind of this weird wildlife sanctuary
situation dad is a wildlife sanctuary he
does its private though which is bizarre
he decided he wanted to open up his own
private wildlife sanctuary so we have
picked kangaroos and we have these
things called bettongs and pata Roos and
these little animals could wor lease I
don't know what any of those are
Australia you just make up ant is not a
joke that's what I was doing all right
that straddling endangered species oh
okay so that's nice so here your father
has his own private sanctuary with all
that like real kangaroos which I've
heard of dangerous no they're not as bad
as koalas I have to say well I was
talking about koalas or like the or the
cutest if you if you google cute animal
koala come
they do not make that noise no I made
that they they're really scary they like
grunts nah I don't think it's when
they're in heat
they're like sexual noises for God's
sake scary it sounds like that and it's
really scary I I used to think it was
the boogie monster when I was growing up
at nighttime that make these like weird
animal noises so I was scared of koalas
in the night yes I thought it was the
boogie monster and I used to negotiate
with them and be like I'm really into
boogies like please like eat my sisters
they're fatter than me like lovely
person I'm gonna first warm bodies is
the movie your love interest in this
movie is a zombie it's a very unusual
idea for a movie and a very funny idea
you fall in love with a zombie boy I
tell you this work yeah he's dead he's
charming he's a charming undead guy he
listens to Bob Dylan he's looks like
Nicholas Hoult who was very handsome
yeah and she kind of worries her he
takes her captive and they spark up this
friendship which turns into a
relationship Oh weird to have a romance
with a zombie though it's a little weird
but you know he doesn't talk back which
is good for us women he's a great
listener and yeah and he's very sweet
and it's funny everything everyone's
been talking about the necrophilia thing
um and I didn't mention it I could tell
no I really wasn't
oh yeah it's funny he's uh his his
dangling starts to work by by the time
we fall in love you called it a what I
that sounds like something it slithers
across your dad's property father I want
to go to a party we have a clip here
from warm bodies let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
safe
[Music]
be the head
it's too much
[Applause]